in izmir the ground has just begun to
shake
and the building on the corner is
trembling
[Music]
an earthquake that started at sea but
brought down buildings across this
region
and spread
[Music]
rescuers responded with a frantic hunt
for those caught in the rubble
locals here said the earthquake had come
without warning
was collapsing down luckily our building
was intact
we were really panicked and managed to
go out at the very last minute
[Music]
the earthquake also caused large waves a
mini tsunami that led to flooding at
least
one person drowned
and here boats swept from their marina
and marooned on land there are reports
that fishermen who were at sea
are still unaccounted for
there were victims too in greece the
island of samos has been badly damaged
flooded and battered two teenagers were
killed here
the effects felt as far away as athens
istanbul
and bulgaria but it is turkey that has
taken the brunt
nearby nations recently at diplomatic
loggerheads with turkey
have offered assistance
but in izmir the grim hunt goes on
for survivors trapped underneath all
this rubble
adam parsons sky news